[Music]
good evening members
members and members of the public
welcome
to tonight's cabinet meeting
just some housekeeping to go through
the fire alarm procedures are if the
fire alarm is activated
vacate the offices via the stairs please
do not use the lifts
assemble in hawley square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber
please can you ensure that your mobile
phones are switched off and turned to
silent
and do not make or receive calls whilst
the meetings imp
meeting is in progress
note this meeting is being live streamed
for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will subsequently broadcast on the
internet
does anyone intend to film the meeting
if that is a no then i will move
straight on
to ask
members well the following members have
been asked
have asked to speak under council rule
20.1
item 5 councillor alban councillor wing
councillor austin and councillor error
item 7
councillor austin and councillor everett
item 12 councillors everett wing austin
uzky does any other member wish to speak
under 20.1
are there any apologies for absence
counselor pew uh apologies from
councillor cup chair
thank you apologies from councillor cup
item two does anyone have any interest
to declare in the items of business on
the agenda this evening
item three minutes of the extraordinary
meeting
to approve the summary of
recommendations and decisions of the
extraordinary cabinet meeting held on
the 8th of june 2021
the copy is attached to the agenda pack
do i have a seconder
thank you councillor bayford do members
agree
item four minutes of previous meeting to
approve the summary of recommendations
and decisions of the ordinary cabinet
meeting held on the 17th of june
2021 copies attached to the agenda pack
do i have a seconder thank you
councillor bayford do members agree
item five asset management
granville cinema to introduce councillor
pugh
thank you chair um as many
as many members of the cabinet will know
um and also members of this council
uh the cinema theatre the granville
theatre has been closed since march 2020
and the council obtains formal
possession of the building in june 2021
and it's safe to say that in its current
form and state it can't continue for
much longer
therefore um it is my recommendation to
move to the council to agree to dispose
of the granville theatre in accordance
with the council's
community asset transfer policy as
listed in option one
thank you chair
thank you councillor pugh do i have a
second one
we'll now go to the speakers um under
20.1
first to speak counselor album
yeah thank you leader um this
is a very important matter for the
residents of rams gates
um as one of the wall councillors and
i'm speaking on behalf of
the three of us councillor huxley and
councillor crittenden
um this asset
or although uh as as
as councillor pugh has just said it is
in need of
a lot of renovation um
it is an important asset to ramsgate
um i'm pleased to see that the option
that you likely to support is the asset
transfer
and it is something that that we in the
labor group will fully fully support
excuse me um the only thing
that i would say is that
within option one it does state
that if the proposal fails to deliver a
viable purchaser within three months
then the building should be progressed
to open market disposal
um i i do think that the three-month
period
is uh is short uh to allow
um any group to come forward with a
proposal um they would need a lot of
work to go into that and
um you know they would need surveys they
would need whatever done on that
um so i i would ask cabinet
um if it could increase the three months
to six months
to to allow
any community group to be able to
formulate
a policy and uh and a
plan to come forward with what they want
to do with it to ensure that the plan is
viable
and that they have finance they have
whatever that is that is necessary
um so on on that
chair i i thank you for that and and i
hope you would you will take on board
what we said
thank you
thank you council auburn um i moved to
councillor wing now but obviously at the
end we can consider
thank you chair uh thank you leader i i
struggle with the assets in ramsgate
because i think we've got an appalling
track record of dealing with our assets
in
in in ramsgate particular that's the
area i know best i'm sure there are
issues in other areas
but they are valued assets in ramsgate
we presently have a rotten
maritime museum a rotten cafe on spencer
square
we have the ice house that was just
handed to a group when there was another
group that been working for four years
there was no payment involved i believe
there we have the westcliff hall that is
presently
that is presently
we have the westcliffe hall that's
presently i believe there are three
pre-applications into planning i've
emailed planning to try and find out
what's going on with that building
and those plans also take in up to up to
except five metres of the cliff top
which none of the residents were aware
of
and now we've got the granville so the
granville
needs to be dealt with in an open and
transparent way and we need to start
refreshing the way we deal with and
dispose of our assets
and that all needs to be in the public
domain i understand there are
at least two community groups that are
quite interested in in that facility and
i'm sure they'll come forward
and i'm in total agreement with uh
councillor alban that giving a community
group
three months to try and run some plans
up and i do believe there are
at least a couple that already got plans
on the go
not it is not a long enough time we need
to give those community
community groups chance to progress
those plans and find the necessary funds
to take the assets over
thank you
thank you councillor wing um
councillor austin thank you leader
um i too would like to support
councillor alban's suggestion that
um six months is a more acceptable and
more
reasonable fairer and more honest
approach to community groups if you're
ici you can turn something around in
three months if you're a small community
group you really can't
but you may actually have some very good
proposals that are well worth the
council considering
i find myself in the groundhog day
position of banging on once again
about the fact that we're in the process
of the ramsgate future discussion
and that that offers a huge amount of
potential
for community groups to raise funds
there are a number of funds available at
the moment
but they wouldn't be secured within
three months greatly welcome
the removal of the 300 grand requirement
which was
unrealistic for community groups do not
i'm afraid support the community do not
i'm afraid support
the recommendation to delegate the
decision to the estates team and that's
no dis
disrespect to the estate scheme who in
my short time as a councillor i've
always found extremely helpful
but that we feel that this is a very
sensitive decision and we've had a
number of sensitive decisions that have
gone to officer delegation recently with
with
unfortunate results uh we really feel
that there needs to be
some member involvement in this decision
making and finally
there is a rumor going around ramsgate
that this building is already sold i
hugely appreciate confirmation from both
cabinet and officers that it is not
thank you
um thank you council austin what we'll
do is we'll round up all the
points at the end rather than not
answering each and one individually
can counselor i believe you want to
speak
thank you thank you chair um i'm pleased
to hear
uh that the council will take the asset
transfer of the building to the
you know to the community group i have
actually put something together
the history behind the granville theater
so if i'm allowed may i read it out to
you please
originally constructed in 1947 on the
site of sunken garden
just across the road from the granville
hotel the granville theatre was built as
an
auditorium for live theater theatrical
performances usually summer shows and
christmas
pantomimes and alternative venue to the
samhod
grantha ramsgate rebellion now a weather
response pub
originally designed to seat 900 people
mainly on the stepped floor but also on
three balconies
and equipped with a three manual compton
theater
organ the granville theater became
renowned
for its summer shows during the 1950s
through to the 1970s often playing
to full houses sadly with the dummies of
british seaside holiday the summer shows
were discontinued
however the venue was still popular with
various
local theater companies and amateur
dramatic societies
after the demise of ramsgate's two
cinemas the kings
and the audience the granville theatre
was converted first into a
900-seat cinema then into three smaller
units
one of which containing this stage which
could still be used as a theater or a
cinema
if required it is now the only cinema in
ramsgate
the building holds happy memories for
countless rams gate people
generations of aspiring actors singers
musicians dancers and specialty
specialty acts have made their first
public performances
on that small slightly sloping stage
many of my friends have told me about
their fond memories
of appearing there in place pantomized
musicals and other events to lose this
building
would be to lose a part of our history a
part of our lives
a part of ours i am sure that it would
have a great future ahead of it
as a community theater cultural center
if if it were to be sold off to a
private investor no doubt
it would fall into disrepair and
eventually be done list
to be replaced by an affordable floods
please save our local theater in support
of my statement
i would like my cabinet colleagues to
make a decision that
would which we have already decided to
do benefit the local community and make
asset transfer of the building to a
community organization
i am aware that kentfield foundation
have submitted a plan
that could be beneficial i'm unaware
if any other interested parties have
submitted development ideas
if so we should consider each idea
individually
as how beneficial it would be to the
community
council sorry um i just got a few more
lines uh
later please tdc could perhaps add a
courtyard
stating that the interested organization
has a certain time limit
in order to convert the premises into a
central community area
allowing access to theater groups
professionals and amateur
schools and other community
organizations ramsgate is my hometown
and i feel that the asset transfer of
the building to our local community
group
would be the best way forward and i hope
my cabinet colleagues
will make the right decision for the
people of ramsgate thank you
thank you councillora there's a lot of
background there um
we had already um councillor pugh has
already proposed that
we retain the building as a
community asset transfer and it will
remain within the community as long as
a suitable community group can be found
to
to meet the needs i will hand over to
councillor pew to just come back on the
question regarding the six months i
understand
that um the initial concern was the
rateable value
um but i'll hand back to
councillor pew on that but i'd also like
to make comment about
the rumor um there
is always lots of rumor around lots of
especially around estates
but um as i've
mentioned in the past that i have no
intention other than to be open and
transparent about this this will travel
through
the um community asset transfer policy
there is it's very it's very set out i
can send anybody the link on it it's
quite a long read
and it needs to obviously
illustrate on how this will be handled
but
i can assure i can assure you that it
will travel through the appropriate
process and rumors are rumors and
we are not really in the business of
confirming or denying whether or not
that
that is the process we will we will
follow through the correct
transparent process
councillor bayford yeah thank you
chairman
i mean it it's great that everybody's
come along to support the granville and
say
yeah what a great place it is and so on
but i just like to remind people
that it was until fairly recently
set up to do exactly the things that
you've been describing as a cinema
as you say the only cinema in ramsgate
there's a theater
it was open to amateur groups
professional groups
they attempted to bring touring shows to
relax into ramsgate
basically the people of ramsgate didn't
support it and that's why it's in the
state it's in today thank you
thank you councillor bayford if council
of pew likes to come back on the comment
on the six months
thank you chair yes and thank you
councillor auburn for your suggestion uh
and it's been echoed by councillor wing
and councillor austin
um i certainly think it's something that
we can consider but of course there's
other considerations to do with that
i believe it's my understanding
particularly business rates and council
tax that we'd be liable for for those
periods
um but also as well what i would say is
if community groups are
incredibly keen to take over the asset
and of course um
i've been sent some details from
interested local groups
you know if they're that well organized
then hopefully with the support of our
estates team and
the team of the council three months
should be long enough to pull together
realistic plans that doesn't mean that
if
something wasn't finalized within that
period that we would draw up the
drawbridge
and forget about it and decide to
dispose of it on the open market
surely not um but i think it's
potentially it could be something that
we could
consider so yeah and of course i'd like
to reiterate what council
ashby said that there have been no
conversations with anyone
uh prior to this this is why it's been
brought to cabinet now
um and it certainly hasn't already been
sold because otherwise what we've been
talking about for the last 15 minutes is
a bit pointless really
um so yeah thank you councillor pugh
i'd just like to hand over to the chief
executive like a word
um yes thank you very much leader i just
wanted to take this opportunity to
remind members that this is
a member environment not an officer
environment and actually i would ask
members
to try their best to avoid making
references to officers
i totally appreciate that the reference
wasn't meant to be derogatory at all but
i would just advise that that's best
just to avoid any comment
on officers and just to remind people
that officers are experts in their field
and they
function within delegated authorities
having said that though obviously where
it's appropriate to invite
involved members in uncertain decisions
and
particularly decisions such as this one
that will of course be something we have
the appropriate discussions with cabinet
on thank you
so cabinet the recommendation is to
dispose of the granville cinema in
accordance with the council's community
asset transfer
policy do you agree
thank you
item six quarter four
tenant and leaseholder service update
to introduce councillor jill bayford
thank you leader this report provides
members of the cabinet
information about the performance of the
tenant and leaseholder services
during quarter four 2021 the report was
previously considered by the ovum
scrutiny committee at its meeting on the
25th of may 21.
since transition of the east kent
housing in in house in october 2020
the tenant and leaseholders service team
have shown improved performance in many
areas
we've invested in staff training and
developed an empowered and motivated
team
we have also improved communication with
our stakeholders
and contract management with contractors
the report shows good progress in the
areas of customer service and rent
collection
areas highlighted for further
improvement include the delivery of the
housing capital program
and the day-to-day repairs we have also
developed an improvement plan for the
services
following consultation with tenants and
leaseholders which highlighted
priorities around the appearance of our
estate areas communication opportunities
for involvement
and digital service access
since transition since transition health
and safety compliance has been a high
priority
and we've been working closely with the
regulator for
social housing our policies state that
the position in relation
to compliance will be reported to
cabinet on a quarterly basis
we've seen steady progress towards full
compliance in the main areas of tenant
health and safety and aim to be ready
for the regulator for social housing to
remove the regulatory
notice served on the council during 2021
i feel the housing team should be
congratulated on the focused and
progressive work done
we've seen sound progress in our digital
systems
we now have an independent cloud-based
database where our our data is separated
from the other three councils
we've recently invested in new software
for the management of health and safety
compliance
i propose the recommendations set out in
the report
[Music]
thank you councillor bayford do i have a
seconder for that recommendation
do members agree
[Music]
item 7 statement of community
involvement review results of public
consultation and adoption
to introduce myself
the statement of community involvement
set out
how the council will consult on planning
policy issues planning applications and
neighborhood plans
the sti was originally adopted by
council in 2007
a review and updated sci was adopted by
council in two thousand twelve
it is considered appropriate that the
sci should be reviewed now in line with
the forthcoming
local plan review and to reflect changes
in methods of communication and
engagement
there is also a requirement under the
town and country planning regulations
that scis are reviewed every five years
the council carried out a public
consultation on the sci review
from the 25th of february to the 9th of
april 2021
this report sets out the main issues
raised in response to the consultation
and any resulting changes to be made to
the sci
subject to the agreement by cabinet the
review sei will be reported
to full council for adoption the council
has considered the issues raised in
relation to the sci
and some changes are recommended in
annex one
members will recall that concerns were
raised regarding the proposal to charge
an administrative fee for processing
lengthy and complex representations to
the local plan
it was not intended that it should
affect the ability of local people to
make representation
and following the consultation it is
recommended that the proposal is not
included in the sci
i move the recommendation to the report
secondly by councillor bayford
councillor everett has asked to speak
under 20.1
thank you leader and um nothing very
controversial to say on this but
um i i just wanted to say that i thought
that the consultation responses
um as reported were useful and
constructive and it looks to have been a
good process
and sometimes we get cynical about
consultations but
um you know i think there's some there's
been some useful input
um as far as the fee proposal was
concerned
i mean we were obviously aware when we
put this forward in the first place
that it might be the subject of
controversy but i think it's worth
saying that
officers presented this idea in the
first place for perfectly legitimate
reasons to save public money
which is what we would want them to be
doing and we decided it was reasonable
to put it forward as a proposal
unfortunately and perhaps predictably
it became mired in misinformation and
misrepresentation by
third parties outside the council um i
know that there was a suggestion that
the decision should be called in
and that councillor bayford uh bob
bateford resisted that
on the basis that it was a consultation
and therefore would come back and it
wasn't actually a decision to do it
and i think the proper process has been
followed i think that um
it's the right decision not to proceed
with it it's obviously too difficult
um a concept for us to get across
without worrying people that we're going
to be charging them for
ordinary activity and in the
circumstances i absolutely
support the outcome but i don't think we
should be shy of putting forward things
which are a bit difficult sometimes
just because some people choose to
misrepresent them uh one comment for you
um in annex one chapter four when it
talks about
how we will consult and he talks about
formal notices
and he talks about newspapers well very
sadly i'm afraid the local news park
newspaper
industry isn't what it was um i'm a bit
puzzled by the fact that we put formal
notices in the kemp messenger i don't
quite know what that means i know that
the camp messenger
does or used to publish a county edition
i shouldn't imagine it has more than 100
readers in than it
so i'm not sure why we would use that if
it means the kemp messenger itself
and i can bring you the news that kent
on sunday sees publication in november
2017
so i don't think we should be sending
them press releases and i'm sure the
media team are aware of that
thank you cancer everett um yes i think
it's
it was a democratic process um for what
it's
what it's there for so i think um you're
quite right in pointing out that a good
discussion was had on this subject and
and the right consideration was taken in
the end i will ask
the chief executive or
estelle if it is a statutory requirement
for us to publish in
hard printed newspapers or whether that
is something that we can obviously bring
into the 21st century thank you
i'm afraid i don't know the uh precise
answer
answer that i think it probably is a
requirement um
so yeah we'll have to deal with that
thank you still yeah the the law hasn't
quite caught up with us on the
technology yet so um
no disrespect is still um
i have another speaker on this um i
go to councillor austin thank you leader
i just wanted to endorse what councillor
everett said
and um most particularly to welcome
obviously the uh
the sorting out of confusion around the
uh
around the charging and to welcome
the proposals to work uh more
include more dialogue with town and
parish councils which i think is going
to be crucial
uh for us to deliver um our objectives
in
in future so um to thank everybody who
has been involved in this and to welcome
the process which i think has been
highly successful as councillor everett
said
thank you very much councillor austin
so it has been moved and seconded do
members agree
item eight annual treasury management
review
to introduce councillor saunders
thank you leader this is where i'm going
to start throwing figures at you
and i start with a generate item 8 and
then
go through to a gender item 11 i think a
gender item aid is annual treasury
management review
this report summarizes a backward look
on our treasury management activity for
twenty
twenty twenty one the figures are
provisional because our twenty twenty
twenty one accounts have not yet been
audited
and are therefore subject to change
until the audit is completed
the regulatory environment places
responsibility on members for the review
and scrutiny of treasury management
policy and
activities this report is therefore
important
in that respect as it provides details
of the 2020
21 year end position for treasury
activities
firstly i'm pleased to report that all
of our activities
operated within the limits agreed by
members
but the other key messages that i would
summarize from the report are
that the capital expenditure was
significantly under budget
as detailed in the following budget out
turn report
that we repaid six hundred and thirty
one thousand pounds
of debt during the year and undertook no
new borrowing
that our average debt position was 25
million
pounds and we did not borrow more more
money
than we needed to finance our capital
program
as such we stayed well within our
authorized limit
of 109 000 pounds
i move the recommendations
thank you second by councillor bayford
there's no one to speak under this item
so i'll ask members to agree i agree
back to you and councillor saunders for
the general fund and hra provisional out
turn
2020 to 2021 thank you
this report presents the provisional out
term for last year
these are what are likely to be the
final accounts for the year
subject to any last minute amendments or
changes
as a result of the external audit on the
general fund revenue position
there is a 30s a free getting ahead of
myself
too much money there is a 3.6 million
oh overspend this compares favorably
with the last
monitoring report in january some of the
overspend is due to the
impact of covet as a range of additional
expenditure was incurred
and income had has fallen almost all
income has been affected
especially off-street car parking
council tax
and business rates that said there will
have been
non-coveted factors that give rise to
the overspend
the two largest are the actual and
potential legal costs
associated with matters being considered
by the investigations and disciplinary
committee
estimated at seven hundred and thirty
three thousand pounds
and the revenue costs of the replacement
birth four
five estimated of four hundred and forty
five thousand pounds
additionally the council had some
pre-existing budget problems that will
not
have gone away these are referred to
in the twenty twenty one twenty budget
monitoring report
also on this agenda they will also be a
factor to consider
in our twenty twenty two to twenty three
budget
the accounting arrangements for council
tax and business rates
are exceptionally complex for the twenty
twenty
twenty one for example business rate
relief was subject to a government grant
that we have to include in the twenty
twenty twenty one accounts
but we will we but we will have to apply
all of the grant
in subsequent years
these technicalities mean that about 10
million pound of our reserves
at the 31st of march 2021 are already
committed
to be used to fund income losses all
districts will have
a similar inflated reserves
position at 31st march 2021
which should not be considered to be
available to spend on anything other
than council tax
and business rates for the housing
revenue account the overall position is
better than
previously forecast this is mostly due
to rent income not being so adversely
impacted by the covet
as planned on the capital programs for
both the general fund
and the hra they are roughly
50 percent underspent on both this is
largely due again to covid
although there were some projects that
would have underspent anyway
setting aside the pandemic once again i
move the recommendations
thank you councillor saunders i have a
second councillor bayford
can i move that greed
moving to um item 10
budget monitoring 2021 22 report number
one
to introduce councillor saunders
thank you you're gonna get bored with me
this is a budget this is agenda item 10.
this report represents the first budget
monitoring position for the current year
the general fund revenue forecast is for
a 2.1 million pound
overspend some of this will be directly
related to covid
for example the need to hold council
meetings at the ramsgate sports centre
rather than in this council chamber
other overspends are not especially
related to covid
for example income losses in property
building control
and clinical waste these areas
have underachieved against budget before
covid and will need to be addressed
in the 2022-20 budget
finally overspends will be due to a mix
of covered and non-coveted factors
such as homelessness this is an early
forecast for the year and hopefully the
pitch will improve
if not we do have just enough covet
grants
that could cover the overspend on
general fund capital
there is some slippage or underspend
forecast
two areas of note are in respect of
toilets
and office accommodation both of these
projects
are dependent on capital receipts from
the sale of toilets and our main
offices until a plan has been developed
that generates enough income for
from sales to cover the cost of any
capital expenditure
these projects cannot go ahead
turn into the health housing revenue
account the main overspend
is the fund the waking watch service in
the tower
blocks as recommended by the fire
service
on the hri capital programme the
substantial slippage on last year's
program
has been comprehensively pre-reprofiled
over the next few years to create a more
realistic
phasing of projects the re-profiling
priorities
the essential health and safety works to
the tower blocks
once again i move the recommendations
thank you councillor saunders council
baker to second
anyone have anything to move all right
do members agree
um item 11
david last one uh insurance tender
very short this one this report seeks
cabinet approval to enter into a new
contract
for insurances the council is required
to ensure value for money when procuring
its contracts and as such we are
required to repro
file our insurance contract before the
renewal date
of january 2022 i
move the recommendation
do members agree
so you you're off for the evening now
david it's um over to me
so item 12 verse 45 port ramsgate
additional funding to introduce
myself
counselor sorry verse 45
briefing note for cabinet that is uh a
long it's quite a long briefing note so
bear with me
in order for the council to fulfill its
contractual obligations to bretts we
must provide a birth for them at all
times for use in connection with
their permitted activities for several
years the births provided
were becoming problematic in terms of
the need for constant
maintenance and repair and ultimately
came to the end of their useful life
initial feasibility and design work for
the project to replace burst
existing birth 45 was focused on a fixed
key
however following an approach by bam
nuttall the use of a floating pontoon
became an option
following a technical assessment by our
consultants
the option of a floating pontoon was
more cost effective and would fall
within the capital cost
allocated to the project
on the 28th of june 2019 we gained
external planning advice
that reliance could still be placed on
part
18 of the general purpose development
order
on this basis a prior approval
application could therefore be made
without the need to undertake an
environmental impact assessment
or to make a full planning application
based on this advice officers proceeded
on that basis
the two options of a fixed key or
floating birth were presented to the
port working party who decided
unanimously that the floating birth
pontoon
should be developed as this represented
best value
legal advice was also sought to confirm
that the pontoons could be purchased in
accordance with the public contracts
regulations 2015.
the advice received was that a compliant
a compliant tender pack and performance
specification should be produced for the
purpose of competing tendering
competitive tendering the documents
provided
additional information which allowed a
better understanding of the scale of the
project that our lawyers had
not had prior to the initial advice
subsequently their advice was amended to
say that
a direct award could be progressed and
would be lawful
record of decision for the realignment
of the capital program was signed by the
portfolio then portfolio holder
the chair of ons subsequently called in
this decision
and the legal advice was shared with the
members of ons
there was then a change in
administration and a new cabinet
requested a report outlining all the
options available to procure a
replacement birth
at the cabinet meeting held on the 16th
of december 2019
option 4 was approved which was a
competitive tender for a single
replacement birth
this was a change in procurement
approach from the previous decisions to
do a direct award
following the competitive tender process
bam natal were the preferred supplier
for the replacement birth
now only utilizing just one of the two
pontoons
on the 17th of june 2020 the maritime
management organisation
informed tdc that we need needed to
screen the project
to establish whether the eia was
required
this was in relation to the construction
of piles to hold the birth in place
on the 17th of august 2020 the mmo
confirmed that an eia was not required
and following this a prior
a prior approval application was
submitted to the local planning
authority
lpa consequently at that time
and based on the advice the officers had
received the project did not require an
eia
and a revised project delivery plan was
shared with the contractor
even though as the applicant we had
received legal advice that an eia was
not required on the 13th of october 2020
the lpa confirmed that they now required
an eia before prior approval application
could be determined
the mmo subsequently reviewed their
position which subsequently also changed
and aligned with the lpa and also now
required an eia
this unanticipated delay has resulted in
a significant increase to the estimated
total cost of the scheme
which has now exceeded the low the
allocated budget
this report provides detail
on the additional scheme cost and
proposes an increase in the budget
allocation of eight hundred and twenty
five thousand
a breakdown of this can be found in
annex one
the report also contains the revised
project program in annex
two which shows the construction phase
now taking place between may and august
2022
a summary of project activity today is
presented
as a timeline in annex 3.
recommendation 1 is that is the report
is for capital environment of
55 000 to the berth 4-5 project
for two from two other existing maritime
capital projects to fund the eia
recommendations two and three are
ordinary decisions for council but are
recommended to cabinet as urgent
decisions
as urgent decisions outside the budget
framework
the chair of overview and scrutiny has
been informed and has given consent for
the matter to be dealt with by cabinet
the matter will be reported to the next
scheduled meeting
of council in september
cabinet please take the recommendations
one and two do i have a second one
i have speakers under this
item first to speak counts councillor
everett
yes thank you i'm sure you'd be
disappointed if i had nothing to say
about this
um you've given a very uh fair summary
of um
of the events um if i may say so um i
will
say as you're aware the the timetable
which forms nx3 to the report
was something that i asked to be
produced
uh prior to the change of administration
and shared with you prior to the change
of administration
and i think it's very important document
because i think that
this project has been mired in confusion
externally quite apart from internally
and the more transparency the council
can bring to
why we are where we are the better
so i welcome the fact that you published
the document which was always my
intention that it would go with the
report when this item came to council or
cabinet
um i also take responsibility on behalf
of the labour cabinet for the decision
that we took in
december 2019
the decision to change the procurement
process was based on
officer advice the balance of officer
advice
there was not people can go back and
read the documents and they can see what
that advice was
it was also based on listening to what
the public were telling us
in ramsgate whether we listen to the
right people
or whether we should have listened to
them um i think it's you know as a
matter for conjecture
but that clearly people didn't did not
want the second pontoon
in the harbour and there were
concerns i think probably based on
misinformation
um about the procurement process and
about the arrival of the bam natal
births
we've always agreed i think politically
that this this
birth needed to be replaced uh and i've
always been satisfied
that the conservative administration
which preceded us
acted properly in what it did and
as i say we take responsibility for our
decisions but i accept
that the decision to go for a
competitive tendering process
has contributed to the delay um in this
project and the delay is the primary
cause of the
extra expenditure what i will say is it
doesn't help that the project took place
in this atmosphere of extreme suspicion
and misinformation people saying that
the birth didn't need replacing
people saying that um the contract
wasn't valid or can some mysterious way
be voided
or the pontoons were part of some
conspiracy i mean we might consider
whether
with hindsight the communication issues
could have been handled differently
but nonetheless that hasn't helped the
council
we believed when we reached that
decision as a cabinet that the tender
exercise was the best option
i think the council was badly let down i
have to say by the marine maritime
organization as a statutory body
telling it that the eia was not required
people outside the council felt that the
council would not or wasn't following a
proper process
it was exactly the proper process which
resulted in the need for an eia being
established
and quite honestly people outside the
council who say
they told the council really was the
council going to make a decision based
on
third-party advice from the community or
was he going to listen to the marine
maritime organization and what would
have been the proper thing to do the
council did the proper things
proper thing it listened to the people
it carried it out its own process
and it made its own findings
what i will say is that subsequent to
that
it's understandable that the mmo changed
its position but the council seems to
have been
put through a particularly severe
and detailed process which seems to be
informed by the suspicion in the
community
so i think we have to say that this is
not a happy story for phallic
none of us in my opinion would want to
be spending any significant amount of
money on replacing births four and five
none of us i think believe that the
contract which the council entered into
many years ago
was a sensible contract but we are where
we are
i take responsibility for what my
cabinet did
and i hope that we can get the best
possible outcome from this project and
take it forward
but we won't do that by pretending that
things which things which are
the fantasy solutions are possible such
as simply voiding the contract
um telling brett's they're not required
anymore or
that we can somehow go off and get some
different kind of birth which is cheaper
we have to deal with the real world and
where we are and i'm sure you'll do that
thank you
thank you cancer everett yes um i thank
you for
sharing these details with me um albe it
was a just a few hours before
i um took the leadership of the council
but
um as soon as um i saw this
i i felt it um
it was my wish to to bring this out as
soon as i possibly could and this is the
first meeting that it could be produced
that because i had to get it onto
um obviously the list and move it into
cabinet but
it is always my policy
in whatever i do is that i always think
it's best to get everything out on the
table
which is now out on the table so that
everybody can
examine the facts and they can look at
it and
hopefully like you say we can move on
with the project
thank you uh councillor wing
thank you leader i suppose i am one of
those suspicious locals and i'm quite
happy to be a suspicious local and it
comes from
not not sharing appropriate information
i believe with with residents after all
we are spending their money
i i i'm doing it in two parts the first
bit is about the the
the money and obviously the second part
is about the eia which i think is
incredibly important
i would first of all like to thank the
leader of the council for bringing this
matter to cabinet
so that residents and elected members
are made fully aware of the issues
involved
as as you know i have on many occasions
requested information and asked
questions concerning this particular
port project
the critical question now that needs to
be answered is
how have we ended up in this situation
with a project that is now 870
825 k over budget it's our
responsibility as elected members to
ensure the council is effectively
governed and provides value for money
and
all that is done with with regard to
this i've been asking myself
have the right things been done in the
right way for the right people or
purpose and in an accountable manner
how can any one of us actually know the
answers to these questions given we are
never
we've never been presented with a
business plan or case
just an emergency response to to an
existing pontoons that were repeatedly
that
we were repeatedly told with our
terminal beyond repair and could foul
during the next big storm
indeed the previous leader stated when
asked by myself that it is not the
responsibility of tdc to produce a
business plan
case the lga council's guide to
procurement begs to differ
and states there are some well
established reasons why major
procurements in local government
fail including an inadequate business
case
i believe at the heart of this situation
is once again the use of
emergency powers coupled with the lack
of business plan and case
this is quite simply a situation that
should never have arisen given the last
engineers report
on the existing birth on in april 2017.
it drew the following conclusions
in general the barge pontoon supporting
birth four and five
five is in fair condition for its age
and if docked shot blast and repainted
it would last for a good number of years
of course we have no idea whether this
work was carried out or indeed if
further engineering reports were
undertaken to monitor the condition of
the existing pontoon
to ensure a well-planned and managed
strategy could be developed to
maintain an effective berth four and
five
the agenda pack page 163
indicates on the 8th of march 2019
there was an initial contact with bam
informing that an aggregate berth on the
river crouch consisting of two large
pontoons were no longer required this is
nearly two years after the engineers
report
so why was the use of emergency powers
to fund an expensive and complicated
project deemed necessary
what was being done considered decided
during this period and why did we wait
for the existing pontoons to deteriorate
into such a critically bad condition
why were we not forward planning we've
always
we've also been repeatedly told that the
bam the ban pontoon is the cheapest
option
but the supporting documentation to
evidence this has never been produced
and it also appears there was no
consideration of a potential repair
refurbishment of the existing pontoon
indeed brett did not ask for the pontoon
to be replaced as confirmed by the
previous leader during october 2019 full
council meeting
so what was the emergency i also believe
that given the use of general permitted
development with prior approval without
the need for a maritime
licence and an eie was not appropriate
i'm sorry sometimes we do become experts
by
doing quite a lot of research ourselves
a simple look at the mmo portal
would have confirmed this given the use
of the bam pontoon
represented a considerable increase in
both size
for 317 percent and a conveyor capacity
of 400
from 400 tons to 3 000 tons per hour
it was neither a repair or a like for
like replacement
and our concerns were justified when the
mmo assessed an eia was required
when tdc then applied for a marine
license application
in addition why have we never seen a
fully costed breakdown of this project
does one exist has one ever existed that
would detail the financial commitment
alongside how this considerable spend
would be recouped and from where
this would have been a critical feature
in any business plan or case
and one that could have informed
evidence-based decision making
looking forward i am aware that brett
will be responsible for replacing the
conveyor system
have discussions with brett to consider
what needs to be done
applied for and from which planning
authority and are they aware that
these works will also require an a
marine license application
and associated additional eia given
these works are not part of this
application to replace births 4-5
without this forward planning i feel
that delays will result in further
additional costs to every taxpayer
in summing up the failure to research
and develop a detailed coherent and well
evidenced business planning case
combined with the use of emergency
powers has resulted in a project which
which with unclear aims objectives
costings for various options
the identification of a need for
appropriate license an eia and a time
frame for delivery
delivery consequently i would strongly
urge the leader and her cabinet that
this project
and the 1.8 million spend on the
railroad berth
again using emergency powers is
immediately referred
for an external audit to ensure lessons
are learnt to better inform future
projects
especially on the pool and that public
money is spent to a minimum
i'm going to go to the eia now it's
shorter
there is no evidence to suggest that at
any time
and our environmental impact assessment
has ever been undertaken
concerning the port or any of the
activities that are undertaken there
it is therefore vital that we get this
right and apply
and apply the highest possible standards
to ensure potential risks of harm to the
environments
and stakeholders including residents
that live within 100 metres of the poor
have a chance to comment indeed as part
of the mm
the marine license application to the
mmo tdc
under sustainable development 0.3 are
required to complete a feasibility study
that involves discussions and
consultation with other bodies
james seymour from natural england
confirmed on the 9th of the 10th
2020 they had not even been aware of the
proposed work until i alerted them
this application goes on to mention the
importance of cumulative impact 0.5
which involves looking at all the
activities which could have an impact on
an area
and how they relate and possibly
interact with each other
to increase possible impacts this
application is directly linked to two
separate businesses
aggregate and cement batching but also
sharing the area close by are two wind
farm operations car important storage
live experts a large derrick birthday
council sorry
i know that you're very passionate i'm
just going to finish it would take one
minute
just sum up because um as well as the
residential areas within sight of the
proposed work and associated activities
all of which sits close to a number of
environmentally sensitive maritime areas
of both national and international
importance
we must that there we must also not
forget the site is now being used as a
temporary site for extended family of
pave travellers
will the leader and her cabinet give all
public bodies stakeholders and residents
living within 1 000 metres of the
proposed site of the replacement birth
a reassurance that they will be
consulted and that cumulative impact
will be a key feature of this eia can
the leader also explain how choosing
the company who is undertaking the work
will result in a thorough and
independent eia
thank you
thank thank you councillor wing um i
would like to
stick with the questions that are
relevant to the decision that we are
making here tonight
regarding your other questions if you
could supply
your comments then i can have a look at
those separately with the officers
concerned
i i can't answer on the railroad birth
and
obviously at this stage the assurances
regarding
the the residence
confirmation and the residence
consultation sorry um we need to look at
that going forward
i have i can't answer your questions i
have summarized them so hopefully i've
captured them and
um from what i ascertain
your the first question was regarding
the engineering report on the old birth
why it was two years after the knowledge
of the of the decay
that the band uh contract was um
this was brought in the why is it the
increase of
uh in size of the new birth and
um whether the conveyor the brex
conveyor belt that needs to be put
stored back on it is subject to an eia
i'm going to have to pass it over to you
gavin sorry i'm not an expert in this
field um
in a lot of fields but not this one yeah
i think
uh chair that if you submit that in
writing we can respond accordingly
because obviously
it's quite a detailed response that you
require
thank you for listening okay
um we'd um i'd quite like to to share
the response
um with all cabinet and all members that
are interested parties in it rather than
just going back so if that was
um okay with with you gavin and the view
counselor
i'll show that to you tomorrow thank you
very much
i next have a counselor austin to speak
thank you
thank you um i just wanted to remind
cabinet members that this area is
very close to a site of special
scientific interest
and and very close to housing
so why we believed that it would not
require
an environmental impact assessment i
can't quite understand
as a new councillor i am struggling to
see
why we needed to bring in two pontoons
one of which is still sitting in our
royal harbour i'm desperately hoping as
chair of ramsgate town council's town
promotion committee
that it won't still be there looking
very ugly during the uh
royal harbour 200 celebrations in
september and i'd be really
interested as a matter of curiosity in
what our plans are for
it had we not spent money on two
pontoons had we
done a light for light replacement at a
cost of perhaps four hundred thousand
pounds
we would have had plenty of money for an
environmental impact assessment and the
resulting costs related to that my
question for
cabinet is whether using an existing
consultant to un
undertake our environmental impact
assessment conforms with best practice
as a lay person i would have assumed
that
for such an assessment should be done by
someone impartial
and external could cabinet police advise
thank you
thank you i'm um
to hand over to to gavin again for um
report regarding the independent
consultant um
but for the little time that i've had to
get it totally involved with this it is
my understanding
that it is only one
of the pontoons that is included in the
overall contract the contract
is for supply of one pontoon
and installation of one pontoon the
other pontoon
remains in the ownership of van nuttle
and from my understanding also is that
they are paying mooring fees for that
second
um so they are paying customer um
what their intention is and where it
goes and when it goes
um i suppose he's up to them um
but gavin you might have more
information on that but if you can
answer the independent consultant
part then i'll be grateful thank you
yeah i think in terms of just clarified
chair for the
the pontoons initially uh
bam nuttall brought them to to the royal
harbour
and then as part of the initial
discussions it was the use of both
pontoons
uh but subsequently when we went for
tender through the competitive process
they're only supplying 1.2 so at this
moment in time actually
those uh none of those pontoons are in
the ownership of tdc they both belong to
van nuttal and obviously as we develop
the project and deliver
the project then obviously they'll be
using those as as part of the
fulfillment of their contractual
requirement
in terms of the consultant obviously the
consultant will use would be
to be qualified to carry out the
necessary assessment
so we would say that actually we
were confident that the assessment would
be appropriate and fulfill all necessary
requirements
uh councillor bayford yeah thank you
chairman i would just like to make a
couple of points
um yeah i was the leader before
councillor everett
and i'd like to thank him for the
comments that he made earlier because i
do think that
this is one of those situations where
when you look back at it
from here it's very difficult to
remember
exactly what happened when where and how
and why
one of the things that counts rivers
said i thought was very telling
was that you know it was right for us to
listen to the people
but there is a question as to whether we
listen to the right people
um it's a question of whether we listen
to the right people
the noise was deafening from certain
quarters in ramsgate
and i would just point out to members
that
as far as i'm concerned the council is
acting in good faith we have a working
port
you know it's designated as port has
been a working port the intention was to
keep it as a working pool
and as far as the movement towards the
band natal situation is concerned
the timeline will show you that on the
25th of july
2019 a port working party met
the attendees were myself councillor
campbell councillor rogers councillor
azeki
councillor everett and we
unanimously thought that it was a good
idea to pursue that option which is what
happened
now i can't comment too much beyond that
because
my tenure as leader ended fairly shortly
and it became counter-everett's
responsibility but
i do think that um there's a number of
things going on here
and some of it includes being wise after
the event because i think it's very
difficult to
to go back and put ourselves in a
position where as far as i remember
and i was closely involved with the port
and had been over many years i mean i
was
portfolio holder for you know marine
maritime operations
probably as early as 2003 so you know go
back a long way
and as far as i'm concerned you know we
were always being put under pressure
for potential losses at the pool many of
which were not real losses i mean
we've been across this many many times
before you know there are
non-cash items in there which uh you
know just just
muddy the picture but there were lots of
people who didn't want to
believe anything other than the things
that they thought themselves
and i just hope that there's none of
that still going on today
but i think there could be and it still
generates an awful lot of noise
um but at the end of the day i hope that
we will
go forward get the eia done and we will
get a solution i would remind everybody
again counselor everett said it but
whether it's good bad or indifferent
we have a contract with brett's you know
you can look back at it and say well
it's good bad or indifferent but at the
time
you know it was a working port we were
cross channel ferry port at the time
and the bret business was very good
business um
you know you could question whether the
length of the the lease
and so on was right but that was that
was done and there's no getting away
from that and as far as i understand it
um if we don't have a birth there then
brex can carry on bringing
lorry loads of aggregate in and out that
pool
at will and i'm not sure what that does
for the environment but
what do i know
thank you councillor bayford um next to
speak cancer is asking
thank you leader um it seems like quite
a few of my questions being answered
tonight or
are going to be answered but there is
one that's still outstanding that
i'd like to bring to your attention and
that is has it ever
been the intention or is it anticipated
that the new pontoon
birth will be used for any other purpose
than processing the mineral aggregates
if so what exactly is planned uh or
under consideration and does it include
any waste movement of any kind
that's it thank you
thank you um again um not been involved
with this long enough and um
i haven't had any conversations
regarding
this with either brett or offices or
whatever but um
i again pass over to to you gavin for
uh for comment thank you chair yeah
i think in terms of the connection of
the pontoons to the
key the the thick fixings
are only sufficient for the uh conveyor
so although the the pontoon's rather
large and can take a vehicle and i think
that's some of the debate
actually there'll be no vehicle access
onto that pontoon the only access onto
that pontoon is the conveyor
and that's it so at this moment in time
there is no intention to use that
pontoon for anything but the
brett's activity
thank you so um i can't say this is easy
for me
um to present this but we're
contractually obliged to do it and
if we don't get on and do it then the
the cost of this council just keeps
going up
so i
will move the recommendations for the
um transfer of budget 55
000 for the eia and for
the capital budget of 325 in the 2021-22
account
and the 275 in into
sorry the additional revenue expenditure
445 recognized in the 2021 accounts
so that is my recommendations do i have
a secondary
members have any other comments cabinet
have any other comments to make
do members agree
so i'd like to thank everybody for
coming out this evening
i think it's been a really informative
cabinet meeting
and this concludes the business for
tonight and i declare the meeting closed
at
8.06 thank you members